Now that you've been introduced
into some of the other
functions that we can take a
derivative of, we can now
apply them using the chain
and the product rule.
So let's do some
fun derivatives.
And I think derivatives is
all about exposure, it's
all about practice.
So I just encourage you to do
as much practice as possible.
And it's actually in some ways
a pretty mechanical thing to do
and it's easier than a lot of
the math that you've
learned before.
Just maybe initially
looks a little abstract.
So let's say that f of x is
equal to let's say the sin
of 3x to the fifth plus 2x.
So what is f prime of x?
What is the derivative
of this function?
Well, we use the
chain rule again.
We take the derivative
of the inside.
So what's the derivative
of the inside?
Well, that's just 5 times 3 is
15 x to the fourth plus 2.
And then we take the derivative
of the larger function.
In the last presentation
we learned the derivative
of sin is what?
It's cosine.
So it's times the cosine of
this expression right here.
3x to the fifth plus 2x.
Pretty painless, no?
Let's mix it up even more.
Let's say that-- let me
switch colors just to
not be monotonous.
I'll pick powder blue.
Very nice.
Let's say that y-- and I'm
going to switch notation on
purpose that you get used to
the various notations
you can use.
Let's say that y is equal to--
let me think of something
good-- e to the x times
cosine to the fifth of x.
That looks daunting to me.
Let's see if we can break
it down using the product
and the chain rules.
We want to figure out dy/dx.
We want to figure out
the rate at which y
changes relative to x.
Or the derivative.
Find the derivative
of both sides.
Well, let's use
the product rule.
Well, we're going to have
to use the chain and
the product rules.
So first we take the derivative
of this first term, and once
again we learned in the last
presentation the most amazing
fact, one of the most amazing
facts in the universe that the
derivative of either
the x is what?
It is e to the x.
Blows my mind.
e to the x.
Once again I've taken the
derivative, and it's
the same expression.
Amazing.
And then I multiply it
times a second expression.
Cosine to the fifth of x.
And now to that I add
the derivative of the
second expression.
Now this will be a little
bit more interesting.
So this is cosine
of x to the fifth.
This is just another way
of writing cosine of
x to the fifth power.
And I think that'll make it a
little bit more clear, that
this cosine superscript
5, this is really just
cosine to the fifth x.
This means cosine
of x to the fifth.
So now the derivative is
a little bit clearer.
We can use the chain rule--
and once again, we're just
working on this right half.
We take the derivative
of the inside.
What's the derivative
of cosine of x?
Yep you're right.
Well, I don't know, I didn't
hear you so I don't know.
I'll assume you're right.
The derivative of cosine of x
is minus sin of x, and that's
something you should memorize,
although you should prove
it to yourself as well.
So we take the derivative
of the inside minus sin.
Derivative of cosine of x is
minus sin of x, and then we
take the derivative
of the outside.
We're just doing
the chain rule.
So it's 5 cosine to
the fourth of x.
So there we took the derivative
of this piece, and then we have
to multiply times
this first piece.
So that times e to the x.
Interesting.
You can simplify this if you
want, but you get the point.
I mean simplifying it from
this point is really
just kind of algebra.
And I think you get the idea.
Actually everything
we're doing is algebra.
If you realize it looks like
something fairly complicated,
but we just use the chain
and the product rules.
Let's do some more.
I will now switch to magenta.
We want to take the derivative
dy/dx of-- let's see,
some big expression.
let me do something creative.
Let's say the natural log
of x over 3x plus 10.
So the natural log of
x over 3x plus 10.
So you could use the quotient
rule if you took the time to
memorize it, which I've never
taught you because it's really
just the product rule.
So I like to just rewrite
this as the product rule.
So they're the same thing.
Once again we're taking the
derivative, so I'm not going to
keep rewriting this, but this
is the same thing as taking the
derivative of the natural log
of x times 3x plus ten to
the negative 1 power.
3x plus 10 in the denominator
is the same thing as 1 over 3x
plus 10, which is the same
thing as 3x plus 10 to
the negative 1 power.
Now we can use the combination
of the product and the
chain rules, and we
can solve this sucker.
So let's do it.
So we take the derivative of
this first term the natural log
of x-- and we learned in the
last presentation the
derivative of the natural log
of x is 1/x, which is
pretty cool in of itself.
And we multiply that
times a second term.
So time 3x plus 10 to
the negative 1 power.
And to that we add the
derivative of the second term,
and we're going to multiply
that times the first term.
So first we're going to have
to use the chain rule.
We take the derivative
of the inside.
Well the derivative of
the inside's easy.
The derivative of 3x x plus 10.
That's just 3.
And then we take the derivative
of the whole thing,
so it's negative 1.
That's 3 times negative
1 times that whole
expression to the minus 2.
3x plus 10.
And of course this whole thing
times the natural log of x.
We could simplify that.
Let's see.
This is 1/x and 3x plus
10 to negative 1.
So we could rewrite this
as 1 over x 3x plus 10.
Let's see.
Plus 3 times minus 1.
So we could say that's the
same thing as minus 3 ln of
x over 3x plus 10 squared.
I think you see how I
got from here to here.
I just manipulated the
exponents and multiplied some
numbers, et cetera, et cetera.
Let's do one more.
Just hit the point home.
You really have the tools now
at your disposal to do a
lot of derivative problems.
Probably most of the derivative
problems you'll face in the
first 1/2 year of calculus.
I'm going to switch to green.
Let's say y-- actually
I'm tired of y.
Let's say that p is equal
to-- I don't know.
Sin of x over cosine of x.
Let's figure out what dp/dx.
The rate at which
p changes to x.
So once again this is the same
thing as sin of x times cosine
of x to the negative 1.
So we can just do the
product and chain rules.
So the derivative
of the first term.
Derivative of sin of x
is cosine of x, times
the second term.
Times cosine of x
to the minus 1.
And then to that we add the
derivative of the second term.
We have to use the
chain real here.
So we take the derivative
of the inside.
Well derivative of cosine
x is minus sin of x.
And then times the
derivative of the outside.
well that's minus 1 cosine of x
to the minus 2, and then we
multiply that times the
first term, sin of x.
So let's simplify that.
So this is cosine of x
divided by cosine of x.
You see how this cancels out?
This is cosine of x over cosine
of x, so this is equal to 1.
Cosine of x divided
cosine of x is 1.
And then this minus sin cancels
out with this minus sin, and
we have sin times sin
over cosine squared.
So this is equal to 1.
I'm going kind of fast because
I'm about to run out of time,
but I think you get
what I'm doing.
So this is sin squared x over
cosine squared x, which
is actually equal to--
what's sin over cosine?
1 plus 10 squared x.
And if you know your trig
identities, that equals 1
over cosine squared of x.
And, of course, what we just
proved is that the derivative
of the tangent of x is equal
to the secant squared of x.
I hope I thoroughly confused
you in that last problem.
I'll see you in the
next presentation.